wenn jetzt das master ich hab' ich habe
trenkel standing so und ich habe auch
noch viele pfeile und den wendigen
wunsch die dir in die fresse zu schießen
service s kids und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video
wie ihr sicher bist gespannt erwartet
heim und wir sind nicht zum spaß ja
deswegen machen wir heute meinen kleinen
reality check und gucken mal was ich
überhaupt kann in minecraft kann ich
überhaupt was kann ich etwas oder kann
ich etwas nicht
wir sind zu diesem zwecke in einer team
sg runde
und wie sieht jetzt nicht wirklich ein
viererteam gefahren oder es läuft ja
okay nicht nein gesagt 460 tsg und
gucken einfach mal wie gut wir uns hier
schlagen
ich hoffe einfach dass wir das jetzt
nicht ganz krass verkackt vielleicht
können wir vorne holen habe ich schnell
damit im internet erschwert natürlich
wegradiert ich ab schlaue burschen
schlauer bursche vielleicht dass ich ein
bisschen näher an mich ran
und ja vielleicht tätig mädchen der ja
du willst doch safe mich mit ihm oder
wie ist die lage
wie ist die lage ja ich schaue mir ja
natürlich schwer bisschen und wir gucken
was ich wie gesagt vielleicht noch drauf
habe oder aber auch nicht ich hab grad
direkt hinein scheiße so gern für direkt
in den 64
thema ist die runde weil wenn schon denn
schon
muss gucken ob die irgendwie trennen
kann ja ok alles klar
ja das ist natürlich dürfe man jetzt
gegen team steht die können jetzt
abwechselnd und boosten sich
wahrscheinlich auch noch das okay ein
erstauntes gestellt das ist gar nicht so
schnell geht ok etwa wir eine
realistische chance deines down der
andere hat seine kidman hat aber auch
nur gute eirund test plate dürfen wir
auch nicht vergessen
okay aber ich kann relativ gut sprinten
also ich will hier kaum hunger irgendwie
das geht ganz gut so weiß er fällt
zurück
er ist gestorben er hat ist jetzt
wirklich geliebt weil sein teampartner
tod ist nicht dein ernst jäger ja okay
gut meint wegner machen was ihm so gut
dann ist er nicht glaube ich jetzt kurz
mal in die mitte und entscheidende meine
jazz plate leute bei mir ist es wieder
richtig richtig waren deswegen
entschuldigt dass ich hier nicht im
anzug oder im sakko sitze sondern ganz
unkonventionell und tanktop das übrigens
einst von max ist danke markt für das
denke ich dank die erste baum spielt die
reittiere rückt noch ein bisschen besser
rein hier ist noch ein helm hammer schon
von james bond
ich habe nicht so dolle orientierung
hier das ist tschernobyl übrigens die
map ich doch ich glaube da vorne ist das
bauen kann es sein kann sein ich glaube
dass ich glaube das ist ja er ist dann
packe ich jetzt kurz mal einen level auf
die schippe drauf sie läutet dezimieren
sich ja mal richtig krass gerade ja gut
man muss auch sagen die runde war nicht
ganz voll im gegenteil man glaube ich
nur 33 leute oder so also eigentlich 33
er ist klar was hier gerade spiele aber
da kann man nichts machen also ich gehe
schon in die team runden weil die besser
voll werden wenn die jetzt hier nicht
ganz voll werden dann
keine ahnung dann ist 64 es geht einfach
nicht mehr in oder so die leute spielen
zum beispiel ist alle bett wars aber das
echt gut weil im bett was lernt man
nicht so sehr den pvp aspekt doch es ist
auch pvp als würde ich zum teil player
versus player auf einem kanal bringen er
wusste auch pvp aber sie ist nicht so
intensiv wie survival games finde ich
zumindest oder wie seht ihr das
in ihr bett das ist genauso eine gute
vorbereitung für furore wie zb games
befindliche petrus ist die bessere
vorbereitung oder findet ihr so weiter
ganzes die bessere vorbereitung also
jede option würde interessieren schreibt
man das mal und mit rein und ich gucke
jetzt mal dass ich den da hinten noch
hole der da ist er da ist der dff apples
japan zu haben ich bin auch alleine
er hatte dort das cockpit nicht meine
hand
es war halt einfach place eishockey tage
dauern sehr schön gut tut mir sein
equipment krass habt ihr das gesehen auf
einmal hat ein kopf webdav gut aber in
sachen bogen danken
februar und 10 kompasse zehn stück
deshalb schon eine hausnummer sondern
auch von iron stetig bräuchten chain ham
nach alter regel sieben heiltränke das
kann sich sehen lassen plus im finale
brauchen wir den kompass nicht mehr
jetzt ist die spannende frage ist das
ein team mein gefühl sagt mir dass es
ein team ist mein gefühl sagt ist mir
so kann aus bis die lage der team- oder
nicht
erst mal hier
ja ich glaub diesem team nicht an locker
sind die teamer
okay der erste station weg ist dann so
unternimmt jetzt finger weg von seinem
equipment
es werde ich mir aber gut ich hab noch
keinen hightech eingesetzt fast so weit
ja die feile jetzt und jetzt was machst
du ich hab ich habe trenkel ist kein
ding so und ich habe auch noch viele
pfeile und den innigen wunsch die die in
die fresse zu schießen komm her sah all
diese bald als im finale
kranebitter es traurig aber beleidigt
mich nicht mehr korrekt tut man ja was
machen wir
läuft endlich soweit sondern hundekekse
weile ganz hinten dranhängen
brad ist am ende 100 erklärt wieso
konnten die dann chatten ist nicht egal
wir springen in die runde kurs gehen so
leute die ksg ist eröffnet die quirlige
es ja scheiße ok oh ich werfe einfach
denn stuff weg was ist los mit mir blut
game ist auf jeden fall nicht und gerade
aber hielt sie mir gerne teams verboten
runde
egal ich hoffe ihr lasst es auch gelten
dass jetzt jemand verbot mache ja kaum
einer der frist holla die waldfee der
gut eingesteckt muss man sagen die
feinen bogen haben jetzt auch wieder am
start
dann ist der nächste tag
[ __ ] [ __ ] das war gut gemacht von ihm
der ist gerade ist nicht schlecht
gestaunt hat er gut gemacht mit dem tnt
mich dann rein geangelt war auf jeden
fall nicht schlecht okay dass die
nächsten da kann ich bestimmt kurz mal
rein
aber kurz hallo sagen dem motto bitte
nicht ist mir ein bisschen turbulent da
hinten vielleicht nachträglich noch rein
und ihr euch jetzt bieten dadurch hofft
durch abliefen diese drei leute und
belauern sich so gegenseitig komme ich
gerne auf den da hinten sollen die
dadurch mehr dinge aushandeln von rd
mein leben ist notre dame von geben
es ist unsere dame wie geht es dir meine
dame habe ich dir ein paar pfeile an den
berner schließen
ja ich glaub auch je nach alter der
gaststätte der junge der mich krass mit
dem schwer getroffen ist er inzwischen
aber ganz schnell
nein nein nein ich hab den ball aber
nicht drin
ok problem er hat scheinbar gute leben
aber jetzt kann ich okay pirlo und beide
erst mal die gelegenheit nutzen bisschen
regen
du bist hier kommen lassen
facebook mit nice okay der konnte mit
noch treffen
er frisst auch also so ist es nicht er
kriegt auch was ab aber es ist ganz ei
ne richtige belagerung lange nicht
vorbei ihr könnt jetzt einfach oben um
auf mich drauf springen quasi also wenn
er da oben lang wirkte was wissen wir
sagen mach was ich mache aber jetzt wenn
man 200 halt macht alles klar
ja dann koran ok kommt zeit kommt voran
so jetzt haben jetzt einfach all der oja
hat die anders nicht schlecht steht er
hat uns haben das glaube ich war kein
herz aber gut leute wenn ich die folge
gefallen hat was gerne mal daumen nach
oben da so das so als als erster schritt
auf dem weg zur vorbereitung von tieren
ein projekt nochmal genau was ich hoffe
ihr habt jetzt nicht den eindruck dass
sie sich komplett untergehen werde
ja und wenn doch dann haben wir sehen
zunächst video wieder rein macht es gut
und